all right people love the internet retro
I can tour here just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell it is
time to create a brand new character
we completed our good Gryffindor
playthrough this playthrough
it's gonna be hard all the way through
and also we are going to create a dark
wizard I did not learn the unforgivables
at all on my first playthrough oh that
one's right over the eye
I actually have a scar right here just
above my left eye when I was a kid I
rolled off the bed in the middle of the
night hit hit a nightstand oh just just
even saying it
just even saying it man
I don't remember it I was too young do
not even remember it happening
I think I like that one right there
all right now eye color I don't even
know what all do they have red
I feel like yellow I feel like yellow
got the most votes alright we'll go with
that
here we go ladies and gentlemen the
start
of our second journey through Hogwarts
Legacy we have completed our run as a
good Gryffindor 100 play through but now
it's time for a little something
different
a little something different
as you are witnessing the birth of mold
retro Mort
himself
I did not use the unforgivables at all
in my first play view other than of
course with the dark arts battle arena I
don't see a glow
in that stuff
big didn't know we had ancient magic
before this moment
that was the first time I saw this that
was immediately what I thought
wait
we did
I forgot it happened right then
this area is so cool but where we're
about to go next
one of my favorite parts of the game
oh I just love this dude this was such a
cool way to start game
oh yeah that's right there's a chest
over here
let me open this please
we're right there
I'm sure it was just coins but
I guess you only have a certain amount
of time or do we have to walk in hold on
thank you thank you I can't remember if
the cutscene makes us walk in
or if I have some time outside
oh yeah yeah there we go there we go 48
okay we're starting our journey right
you guys
Lord retro Mort must have lots of gold I
wonder if you made instructions for vote
and close the door wait this was just
such a nice nod to the old games
having the little Trace like that
the very some of the very first games on
on PC
oh there's one of those guys man
that they they hide these dudes
throughout the game
I heard it was related to Fantastic
Beasts or something something with
newt's Commander I need to look that up
and see exactly what those guys are for
all right here we go combat time
intro to combat we are on hard mode
I can't remember if you know Stupify
right away or not
let's see we'll find out right here
I don't think you do
hit me oh fig just dominate
okay you do knows to fight yes
exposure
that's crazy that you have it right from
the beginning of the game
oh that one caught me
oh I didn't even know there was another
one all right it's back up let's back up
one two three four that fourth one
that fourth one is the powerful one
of the basic cast
stay close all right I'm right here dude
let's cast lumos
what happened to him right there
Professor where did he go come on hit me
so it hits for six and then 30.
it only hits for three wow so stupid
fight doubles it
[Music]
[__]
is that is just another great benefit of
stupefy
the fact that they take more damage
not just more damage seemingly double
the damage
I don't know if that how that scales
once you start learning the other spells
and all that like maybe it's not
double across the board
there you are
how did you how did you fig where did
you go is this place I don't know
but I found this floating above the
Basin the man just vanished he was
standing right beside his face
that is offensive
for viewing memories
you shouldn't be able to operate Wonder
in Gringotts
I wonder
here we go
Follow My Lead
[Music]
so cool man
our first introduction to
Percival Rackham
in the keepers
[Music]
I have no patience for traitors
where were we
I'm not giving you anything
um well
do you think he killed that God friend
here will be more healthy
or is that guy still alive
we never get to see him again do we
[Music]
it wasn't green like it wasn't AKA Magic
oh this part's so cool
I was mad when we didn't get to fight it
right here
this like ancient Guardian
but
but later
foreshadowing foreshadowing
music dude it's so good
and we out we have a sorting ceremony to
get to
oh I still get chills watching this
moment man
[Music]
you get the train
the owl
that hint of hedwig's theme
and then the shot of Hogwarts
oh
so epic man
[Music]
I love hearing Alan 2 the game director
talk about that moment
because he said that they felt like they
needed to earn that so that's why they
had all that intro sequence stuff
I mean because obviously you could have
went right for that you know you could
have went there from the beginning you
could have had us started Hogwarts if
you wanted to but they didn't instead
they chose to
sort of prove themselves I think is how
he described it like they wanted to use
that beginning to kind of say look
look what we can do look what look look
at the stakes
and then you get that
so good
perhaps you belong in Griffin
it's where we originally belonged
that's where we originally belonged but
not today
oh yeah eagerness for power
Lord retro Mort is born
the Dark Lord will rise again
you belong in all that grin
that's so creepy
all right so let's get a good look at
these Slytherin common room this is my
first time seeing it in its entirety of
course I've seen the videos leading up
to it leading up to the game okay that's
pretty cool right there I like that now
initially I will say just going in going
in Slytherin is my least
anytime I've done any kind of test
Slytherin always comes out at the lowest
so this is a very different kind of
playthrough for me I'm curious to see if
I
like the common room though I will try
to look at it objectively so it looks
like that's where I need to go but let's
explore over here just a little bit
first oh okay I do like that that's kind
of cool sixth ears right there
and so then we had the fifth ears right
there so I'm assuming this is the boys
side fourth Year's there let's see can
you go in all of these you can indeed
now the question is do they just have
one because there's no way one two three
there's no way there's only three fourth
years
now this is very cool this area right
here I love the staircase
love the staircase
lots of stone in this one I feel like
the stone is way more prominent here
in the Slytherin common room compared to
the others this
let's see what is that is that like a
little dragon
oh
repero I don't know repair yet whoops
yeah I don't think you can go to the
girls side I think there's something
that prevents it
there you go
how about we jump oh they didn't feed us
any dinner last night guys so we're just
gonna have to fill up on cakes here
All the Little Sweets that they have
left around
cupcake right there all right I think we
should be good
I think we should be good since they did
not give us any dinner at all got a
little uh
assortment of nuts there all right get
us a little bit of protein from the
peanuts to balance out all the sugar all
right you know what let's have a
let's have something healthy to Apple
all right we're good to go
all right here's the dude right here
Sebastian we find him reading of course
if you guys remember if you've played
through the main story you'll know his
parents
were professors
come on giant squid
where are you at
where are you at giant squid
oh there he is
there he is
he's like enough stop
all right fine moving on we'll leave you
alone
I guess you could do it at any window
too
this is your Wizarding level XP earned
from challenges increases your level in
power
you've got yep yep yep we know this
oh
it's so weird to see it go from 100
across the board to
a single one percent okay so we have oh
the house
I never forgot about Slytherin house
fanatic
might Rock the Kelpie robe for a bit
from our collector's edition but then
yeah eventually we gotta go dark arts
eventually we gotta go dark arts
I'm gonna go Kelpie robe for now
oh dude look at him walking up into the
class with the hood on
cracks me up
so you are the new student
have you met Professor Ronan yet we have
not
Shall We Begin fellow Slytherin
confident that we will take hold with a
passion and rigor requisite of such a
challenge I think Corona might be my
favorite Professor please open your
textbooks it's tough because there's so
many good ones
before we begin
anyone here tell me the difference
between the incantations of the color
change and growth charts
anyone anyone
um
I am afraid it is too late to study now
hmm
by the seven months must have really
taken a toll on you all
by the looks of it you all spent your
holidays chart for you
I mean they did such a good good job
with their backstorys and stuff even
remember how to perform personality
summoning John
I could definitely use that one Ronan
teach me
the entire need of review
everyone get into Pairs and take
positions on opposite sides of the
classroom
now let's put those textbooks to use as
the blunt objects you so believe they
are and they turn summoning them out of
one another's hands only one book will
be needed per partnership Miss Dale
thank you get into place now
Samantha Dale
I'm remembering all these quests too
tied to each of the other students
all right oh I didn't hit it
it's still registered it I hit it just a
little bit late
that is not bad
you are a swift learner I see a lot of
potential but remember
potential is nothing without practice
keep at it
you might just rival miss onai here yeah
let's go I'm ready for uh that's enough
of that well someone's score I have the
basics down and it is an exception
ourselves a little Excursion outside for
a spot of fresh air
after me
yeah let's do it
let's see how bad I am after I after
beating all five of the opponents we
should be pretty good at this
fears
can I not change the position
I do not want accio right there
I guess we have to
[Music]
stop
nice
very good
stop
so yeah if you stop it like right around
yellow
let go right around the yellow area
see if we can knock it off
come on let's go
but the
by dueling let's go Sebastian
and protego what about Stupify Professor
can I use Stupify
definitely not our first duel
uh-oh
okay she didn't get mad that we cast
Stupify
but yeah if you guys didn't know make
sure you go back and talk to professors
because then you get more about their
backstory
and some of them are pretty cool pretty
cool info heckets especially
I've jeweled enough consider yourself
lucky I held back
chill when you aren't oh dude
playing the bad guy fit for a certain
exclusive unsanctioned dueling
organization
sounds intriguing exclusive and
unsanctioned Count Me In excellent all
right natural gray let's do it because
this guys if you haven't played the game
yet once you make this choice right here
you cannot change it you cannot change
it you will unlock one handles later on
and those are customizable you unlock
more throughout the game
but this this right here all of this
it is a set it and leave it nothing more
evil than a bright pink light right if
you're doing an Umbridge play through
yeah the handles do make a big
difference and also I find that certain
handles look better or worse with the
color of the wand here so my other one
and my main playthrough was black now
this one's white so it'll be very
interesting
to kind of go back and compare now what
do you think
oh let's go ancient magic time
oh that that grin
looks so evil another one another
beginning of a bright and magical
all right tones and Scrolls though I
totally forgot to talk to the guy so we
need to go back in we got the page and
then just left okay now this right here
opens up
I think there might be another page up
top here
I think there's another one up top
let's see right here oh no a chest
though okay
and we got ourselves a wig and weld
potion
you sir
Don't Mind If I Do all right let's talk
to you
sir I'm here for the spellcrofts
professor Weasley ordered all right Seb
let's do it
troll time ladies and gentlemen
troll time
X
okay our first intro to dodging
in combat when you see the red you have
to dodge
dude we pretty much can't do anything so
we don't have the ancient magic throw
yet
we don't have for pindo
ouch
we can't do this
oh wait we do have
we suddenly have ancient magic throws
let's go
ancient magic throws so good
come on do the slam
thank you
levioso not doing much on this guy
he just took out Sebastian
come on do the other slam
no not that one
the big one
he's not gonna do it I think he's done
[Music]
he's gonna have to keep slamming and
then
this is a hard mode by the way guys so
right when you got to me
no I will not use the Wigan weld
I will not use it
it's the camera that's getting me in
trouble right now
there it is I knew I saw another Barrel
over there nearby yeah there you go
Sebastian distract him
there it is
stupefy all right more damage more
damage more damage oh we did it again I
wasn't expecting that or I would have
there we go
oh we're getting close getting close
this one I feel like is programmed
differently
yeah see he's just spamming this attack
now
the other ones that you meet later in
the game they don't do that
they kind of have That Swing Swing then
the big one
that they follow
all right saved all our wiggin welds
ancient magic here we go
so in this playthrough Sebastian's
getting a firsthand look at all this
in my original playthrough I did not
take him so he had so many questions
later
hello ravelio page
oh here he comes from the toilet bowl
it's the same student too
oh my goodness
all right we can't do that one yet we
can do
Rebellion
I know there's I was about to say I know
there's another one
I know there's one nearby here the map
okay
native of the native home of the
meridian black dragon
and then there's one right here whoa
hold on
oh my goodness
multiple peeves
[Music]
what
I did not know that could happen Peeves
in two places at once Lachlan the lanky
a tall slender wizard who appears quite
proud of himself for what precisely no
one knows dude I think that was because
so we triggered that moment over there
and he hadn't finished it yet but then
we triggered another one right here
which I think this one's actually random
the one over here I feel like that's
kind of a set thing that people see
every time they first enter that hallway
all right cross once time let's go
uh I did take him down for dueling then
you've come to the right place how does
cross wands work exactly we know how it
works let's get into this battle
I'll join your Club of course
I'm ready let's do it
let's do it Lord retro Mort
must make his presence known
hard mode Astoria Cricket oh so it
automatically puts Sebastian with you
the first time I guess
[Music]
Lucy welcome in
wait why is it targeting oh my goodness
it switched to targeting for the other
one
I can definitely tell they have more
health for sure
Sebastian got that guy over there
oh the barrel
and we secured the victory
ready for another round
yep I'm ready that's why I came to talk
to you buddy
no we're going at it alone let's get to
it
we're going alone ready to get
Constance dagworth
apologies in advance Hector Jenkins
apologies in advance
if you were to uh
stupid fight
oh missed it
come on
no
why'd you start shooting at them
oh because I think I took out the other
one
foreign
see I have to wait it's not charged up
enough yet
now we're good
all right not too bad not too bad
they got me a couple times but
barely took any damage I'll take it I
gave it my old you didn't
they're the Duelists have already taken
notice of you but after that last round
they'll really have it in for you
all right Sebastian
can you get me in there you are there
you are you promised me an explanation
for what happened in the three
broomsticks not many students have
Victor rookwood's attention
what was that all about
it's to do with ran Rock seems to
straight up tell you man rock is after
something I found at Gringotts ran Rock
and when were you
fig and I ended up there after the
dragon attack
it's quite the tale fig had this portkey
a port key to Gringotts I'm not sure I
follow I barely follow myself and I was
there anyway we ended up in an ancient
Vault where we found a map anyway that
map leads to the Restricted Section you
can't be serious deadly serious
Professor fig has insisted that I not
tell the story about any of this
get us in there understood your secret's
safe with me
whatever it is thank you Sebastian
you mentioned being clever enough not to
get caught in the Restricted Section and
I am
meet me outside the library tonight yes
let's go
see you tonight dude I'll meet you later
all right let's do this Sebastian
yep we know about that
oh I didn't even know this dude was over
here
oh my gosh I didn't
oh dude that's what I get for trying to
talk to you guys at the same time try
again okay okay okay okay
yeah we do have the uh the dark arts
robes
I should put those on here in a bit
all right
I forgot we need to do it right away
all right go on buddy move on
portrait trying to give us away
all right so they're standing right in
front of that door no no no no no no
on back up back up back up back up
oh that was close
do you guys know on on the harder
difficulty do they detect you sooner or
anything
because I don't think I ever got caught
in this section the first playthrough I
was playing on normal
I mean that still wasn't too bad but I
just needed to wait for them to walk
over here
find the bookcase
told me the library
gone by now
I said usually but it'll still be all
right do you see her desk behind me yep
we see it the key is in the drawer of
that desk now here's what we're going to
do I'll create a distraction to draw her
away you focus on getting the key I'll
meet you outside of the Restricted
Section
good idea you distract I get the key
understood I said I'd get you in and I
always keep my word you were so bad
oh
dude it just immediately put me right
there out of the cutscene
there she is
all right so we gotta wait for her to
move right
there he goes
did you just now hear that
okay wait which side she's gonna okay
she's gonna go that way
oh
together
abandon okay hold on we don't have time
to read it
she's gonna come back here it is
oh no no
no
she's coming back
I think we're still good
still good we're still good we're still
good
I shouldn't have stopped for that note
we cannot worry about the notes right
now hunter green corduroy robe
I will take you
drool
all right so we got the key to unlock
dude what is this book over here
very interesting it looks like a dagger
on the front of it
and then a jewel at the top
I don't even remember that on my first
playthrough
oh that one's Charmed to look more
useful than it is it's fooled me twice
never judge a tone by its cover I say
Charmed to look more useful than it is
oh I forgot I didn't even oh wait wait
wait wait wait
what's that map
okay that is an upgrade though we're
just gonna change the appearance to
where it
it's the scars man let them see the
scars
let them see the scars what do you mean
evil playthrough isn't that how you're
meant to play through it I feel like
that's how most people play through it
yes but not me
not me not on my first playthrough
anyway
all right yeah we can use that to the
lure see this mechanic I really wish
there would have been more
moments that
needed this
but there was just not too many
scenarios where and I know some people
don't like stealth so maybe that's why
oh no they turned around this way now
another one here
no stop looking over here
don't mind me
there we go look at that hand he's
stalking about
so many oh it went back in I did not
remember that from my first playthrough
either so many little details you've
been looking for
yes here we go
there it is
foreign
and then we're still not still not to
the map chamber though
guaranteed piece of legendary
uh we're really not gonna need that
anymore I don't feel like
so we'll just put lumos over there
not surprising God's at the ready
oh dude I love fighting these guys
especially once you get that ability
where you can
fire their weapons back at them
oh there's another one over there
let's see what the ancient magic looks
like on them the lightning strike let's
go
nicely done
accumulates successful 10 plus hit
combos will begin generating ancient
magic power-ups collecting these will
greatly fill your ancient magic meter
and recover a small amount of Health
it's about to say come on guys you know
you're gonna attack
all right so 33 and then 169 after
Stupify
so that's more than double
I was just seeing how many it would do
on him
okay so still 129 at the end interesting
I don't need to heal do you guys know
that if you win a battle
it's still said tap to heal but if you
just wait you'll automatically heal
I probably wasted so many wig and weld
potions because
I thought you had to always heal your
health so like if you finish a battle in
your week I thought you always had to
use wig and Weld and heal up but
apparently not yeah these guys are okay
I was about to say they're totally going
to attack
okay that only did 65.
oh missed you
where is it there it is
who else wants to battle all of you all
right fine
85 right there on the last hit okay an
85 right there all right let's not shoot
stupefy at one
65 okay
but when you get stupefy for that extra
damage
definitely worth it man
that's why I rated protego and stupefy
my
number one spells if you guys haven't
seen that YouTube video
so many people are like I never I made
it through the whole game didn't you
stupefy well you were missing out
weren't you
because of the extra damage
that you could do whenever you hit hit
an enemy with it
they've been finisher in the game oh
yeah when you when you get that sword
and you get to the ancient magic and
fire it back
it's so fun I agree with you I think it
is for sure my favorite move in the game
all right we're we're getting close man
closer to the map chamber
this scene obviously very very important
for the main story of the game
particularly that girl there the young
girl
we are not yet I know we're still not
there not yet
I'm gonna be racing through on my other
playthroughs
just skipping all the cut like this
right here we could skip this but for
the for this playthrough I'll keep it in
I guess we're posting this later to
YouTube guys if you're watching this
live later on YouTube
make sure to leave us a comment in the
chat like the video
don't forget to subscribe if you're not
yet
a subscriber here on the YouTube channel
and also know that you can watch live
over on Twitch that's where we're
recording this in real time
retro raconteur across the board
twitch.tv YouTube Twitter that's where
you can find us
[Music]
so yeah the dad the boy and the girl
right there and then obviously these
Wizards here
very important to the story
you wanted to see me I had mistress
Fitzgerald Professor Rackham this is the
Dora morganock welcome
Professor Rookwood Professor Bacall we
understand that you are adjusting well
to life at Hogwarts
I am
I am glad
especially in life of your own YouTube
Welcome in Uso starting as a fifth year
as it happened I was also admitted to
Hogwarts as a fitness
I've heard of another like us miss
morganock
when we spoke yesterday after class you
asked about the beautiful swirls you saw
years ago when we visited your Hammer I
recognized you all immediately
thank you enough for what you did we
were glad to help and yes I did see
swirls of magic everywhere that day my
father insists it was My Imagination
Running Wild but it was certainly real
to me it was not your imagination
Percival Professor Rackham can see them
too but we have never known of another
who could
I don't understand what are they The
Whispers or traces that appear when a
particular form of ancient magic is
wielded ancient Magic
few are capable of wielding it Hogwarts
itself is a stronghold of ancient Magic
so if I can see traces of ancient Magic
with the proper training but let us not
get ahead of ourselves Miss Morgan
before I can train you to wheel they're
like slow down you must burst master all
that Hogwarts has to offer
a magic this powerful can do great harm
in the wrong hands it must be wielded by
a select View
ERS that you not speak to anyone about
what we have discussed here today
yeah I know Anna the fifth year thing
it's so interesting
like what is it about the fifth year
Sebastian
so what was he doing that whole time
by now
he's been stalling I guess I must take
takees in forms me that you didn't come
alone tonight
someone has coerced you I would have you
tell me
look at peeves behind her you're a
bright boy
look at her don't waste this
he's just gleefully enjoying this there
was nobody else
I came alone
oh Sebastian
what will your uncle say dark arts seven
how's it going dude welcome in welcome
in first time on here
hey appreciate you stopping by checking
out the stream I know a lot of you guys
found us from the YouTube channel
and I know some people don't do twitch
or they I mean pretty much everybody
does YouTube I feel like but some people
don't you know prefer one or the other
so
appreciate you guys showing support
across the board
regardless of where we're hanging out
and streaming
the old librarian one of the first
Librarians of Hogwarts is depicted here
rumor is that he had no tolerance
whatsoever for noisy students and was
known for his liberal use of the
silencing charm at the slightest sneeze
come on bro
silencing charm for a sneeze you gotta
be kidding I'll see big we gotta find
this map chamber dude there's a trophy
trophy we need your one work is
improving by the day
but you'll want to pay attention in
herbology and potions there's more to
Magic than spell casting plenty to keep
me occupied while you're gone you've
done exceptionally well I look forward
to seeing all that you've accomplished
when I return
oh and don't neglect your friends you
may be surprised by how much you can
learn from them as well
all right 4 out of four main quests It
also says we have uncollected Rewards
so let's go to our challenges here okay
so under quests now
yes the legendary Cape that one's pretty
cool
and then we can claim this one as well
that one
all right Nat's eye let's go to the next
I like the next Quest I was there
yeah don't worry about me if you
why were they looking for you
I'm just telling everybody this place I
don't care when were you
just before we came to whole no reason
to keep it a secret that's why I was
late to the Sorting ceremony a portkey
brought us there after the dragon
attacked our Carriage what on Earth
there's one more thing
it's a bit odd if I'm honest Professor
fig says I have around the assignment
good point yeah you need to do the Dodge
what does that mean
Sergeant incendio but I can see traces
of it and I've cast magic I can't
otherwise explain I know that's a lot to
absorb it is
and I will have more questions
for now it is safe to say that you are a
threat you have lots of questions still
to all of us
which is why I wanted to speak to you
ah the dog bugs
foreign
yes
dude they're pretty stout
before you have this window
so we can still do levioso on them which
would
oh it was too late
see we can still do that let's see if it
does
uh
not as good as defendo but
we shall learn that in due time
oh I was too late that time it's
it's no I refuse to heal
if you turn this into a no-heel
playthrough
aside from the very first one that you
have to use
there we go
no Wigan welds for us
[Music]
pull it up
oh I try to get a screenshot
I think I was too late
[Music]
why didn't you tell us this before
screaming the directions
nope not taking my time Leander we're
ready
oh wait I will take this though
stock up on some plants while we're here
all right I don't think you can grab
anything oh wait wait
I did hear that though
I did hear that
this orange radish like fruit floats
upside down as it grows some believe it
can enhance one's ability to accept the
extraordinary
okay then we have to unlock that door
later on
I hope you were able to take care of
everything I had asked you to do
we took care of it heckett we took care
of it we're ready
and you're ready to learn Expelliarmus
pay close attention
the disarming charm May often be all you
need to defeat the most powerful dark
witches and wizards you might encounter
spell casting requires a focus all right
pretty straightforward one here
pretty straightforward
good work the dummy is here if you wish
to stay in practice
do I want to practice
sure why not
but Expelliarmus there
is
later on man we're gonna be able to put
the curse effect on Expelliarmus
and send you
all right very cool do we need to talk
to you again oh she's just
I was like wait did she just leave
you just totally bailed nah she was
still there okay next Quest let's see is
this the one
are we finally ready no there's a
potions class
oh it's it it just arrived
it just arrived the official game guide
so obviously I have not had time to look
through this yet having just
just picked it up